esa es la munición que vendemos nueva
escocia es la provincia donde más ha
aumentado las ventas de armas en los
últimos años pero alex penique cree que
esta industria en auge ha llegado a una
encrucijada el gobierno ha bloqueado la
importación de armas él piensa que es
una medida extrema
es como un corte más en la muerte de mil
cortes tarde o temprano la bestia muere
river
plate la gente tiene miedo de comprar
nuevas armas de fuego porque no saben si
la ley cambiará mañana
las restricciones temporal pero el
primer ministro de canadá dice que
quiere bloquear la compra la venta y la
importación de pistolas al nivel
nacional
nada puede volver a alfred wong que fue
víctima de un tiroteo en vancouver
cuando tenía sólo 15 años y como
gobierno como sociedad tenemos una
responsabilidad de actuar para prevenir
más tragedias
words and cities muchos canadienses
apoyan la ley 621 pero algunos
argumentan que es un fracaso según la
policía de toronto 8 de cada 10 armas
usadas en crímenes se consiguieron en el
mercado negro aún perdimos utiliza no
puedes desmontar partes de un coche o de
cualquier vehículo e introducir paquetes
obviamente puedes transportar drogas
pero la gente también transporta armas
utilizando este método
la policía dice que las armas cruzan la
frontera entre eeuu y canadá todos los
días
el gobierno necesita reforzar el control
fronterizo para frenar la entrada de
armas que terminarán en las calles de
las grandes ciudades de canadá
el ministerio de seguridad pública de
canadá invertirá 250 millones de dólares
hasta 2026 para luchar contra la
violencia y el tráfico de armas